with the spiderman sony disney deal up
in the air right now unfortunately the
future of spider-man is unknown but we
have recently found out some news that
could be a game-changer for the
situation how's it going everybody it's
Warren and we'd all love for spider-man
to stay in the MCU but what if he stayed
in the MCU in a different way than you
thought he would or what if Sony goes in
a different direction than you thought
they would take spider-man as well well
this could possibly happen as right now
there is talk going around that
spider-man could possibly get his own TV
show this is something that fans could
really get excited about as a
live-action version of a Spiderman TV
series has not happened in many many
years of course we have seen many
spider-man animated series throughout
the years but besides that spider-man
has really only been seen through Sony
or the MCU so let's break down why
everybody thinks that we could possibly
be getting a live-action spider-man
series with Tom Holland quick reminder
if you'd like a chance to win an Xbox
one or ps4 be sure to subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment with
your favorite superhero or villain for
your chance to win I'm picking a winner
at 500,000 subscribers so this news
buzzing around that says we could
possibly be getting a live-action
spider-man series kind of started from
Tom Holland himself it started with an
interview that he did with GQ and he
sort of went online as himself and
started to troll fans and this is what
happened that made everybody freak out
I hope one day Tom Anand would have his
own TV show because that would be
amazing well you might have to wait that
long so you heard it from Spidey himself
a fan said that they would love to see
Tom Holland on a TV show and he said
well you might not have to wait that
long now of course this may not be about
spider-man but let's think about the
renegotiation of the contract and deal
between Sony and Disney Disney is
launching Disney Plus stories that are
connected to the MCU and as we have seen
a whole slew of announcements for shows
that are coming to Disney Plus on Marvel
side it would make sense that they could
possibly want a spider-man Disney Plus
TV series because if you think about it
there are a lot of very important series
coming to Disney Plus that are going to
tie directly into the MCU
and movies the Loki series is going to
tie directly into Thor love and thunder
in fact it's been rumoured that Loki is
actually going to be the one to bring
Mele near into Thor at love and thunder
in the main universe of that Jane Foster
can wield Mjolnir and become a lady Thor
then you have the Wanda and vision
series that are going to set up the
events for Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness and we know that
the Scarlet Witch is going to be in that
movie as well they just announced Miss
Marvel and she will probably be in the
next Captain Marvel movie so these shows
coming to Disney Plus are very very
important and fans love Tom Hollands
spider-man why not give him his own show
perhaps this is one reason why Marvel
wanted to renegotiate a deal with Sony
Disney and Marvel would like to use him
in a Disney Plus series while also on
the other hand Sony knows that
spider-man was really made big through
the MCU and I'm not talking about big as
in everybody knows who spider-man is I'm
talking about the last spider-man movie
did over a billion dollars but now
everybody is expecting big things to
come from Tom Hollands spider-man
so perhaps Sony could be thinking of a
series as well now like I said this
could simply be Tom Holland doing a TV
show that has nothing to do with
spider-man but with how important that
Disney Plus shows are going to be to the
MCU and the fact that Sony and Disney
are renegotiating the contract for
spider-man couldn't mean that we may be
getting a show for him unfortunately we
will have to wait to find out but let me
know what you think about this would you
like to see a spider-man Disney Plus
show let me know what you think in the
comments section also don't forget to
comment with your favorite superhero or
villain like this video and subscribe to
my channel so you can enter my giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4
and stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU don't forget to
follow my new personal Channel and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof